when you think about some of those
growth stocks i think tesla's probably
one of the the biggest ones one of the
most popular ones uh i know that you're
a huge fan of elon uh and of tesla talk
to me a little bit about what uh what
you think about uh kind of that business
and and uh maybe headwinds or tailwinds
that it has
well tesla i would say is the exception
to all the things i was just saying
because they're executing so well and
the environment for tesla couldn't be
better with you know gas six dollars a
gallon here in l.a all you see are
tesla's like everywhere now you know so
like you're almost like an idiot if you
go out and like i saw somebody just
bought a new explorer in my parking lot
and i'm like you must be like an idiot
you know it's like you're gonna pay six
dollars a gallon for 15 miles a gallon
in traffic or 10 miles a gallon in
traffic in la i'm like you're spending
150 dollars a week just driving your
kids around baseball and stuff and i'm
like i spend nothing
you know i'm like if you don't like
inflation you go buy an ev it's simple
as that and so people are and so the
demand is far outstripping the supply
and the real game is supply can we make
cars and and with china that's just been
a huge problem so china is the biggest
problem for the global economy right now
it makes interest rates seem like
nothing
honestly like i don't even spend any
time worrying about the fed
i'm worried about china because we make
a lot of stuff in china we make cars in
china we make phones in china we make
half the stuff i own make stuff in china
you know and china is like
whack-a-mole with
covid which is definitely a losing game
and you know it's a mess it's just a
mess so it's hard for tesla to
manufacture right now in china which is
their best market to sell and
manufacture and we have new plants that
are coming up in austin and in berlin
but we're you know 12 months from
efficient you know production
and so it's a really great time for
tesla right now but but this is a super
challenging time as well hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time